on retrouve envoyé spécial depuis le
Dombas cette fois bonjour à vous Karim
vous êtes dans la région de doniels que
c'est dans l'est du pays vous avez donc
quitté le sud vous avez tourné avec
toute l'équipe et on imagine bien que la
réalité est très différente entre ce Sud
libéré et l'Est ou les combats se
poursuivent depuis maintenant des mois
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que les deux fronts ont un
visage très différent on était du côté
de frèresson et de l'arrière-pays de
Helson où on a rencontré une population
soulagée qui nous a expliqué qu'elle
respirait enfin mais qui restait
traumatisé par la présence russe il faut
noter que les frappes russes continuent
dans la région et frappent à l'aveugle
un certain nombre de localités mais
essentiellement aussi la ville de
frèresson encore tout récemment et bien
des transports publics ont été visés les
frappes Russes se ment la mort un front
qui a des allures de front figé où
chacun reste campé sur ses positions
mais où l'artillerie frappe notamment
l'artillerie russe en direction de la
région de Herson avec des ripost du côté
des des Ukrainiens du côté de Donetsk où
nous nous trouvons la situation est très
différente le front est plus actif nous
sommes allés à la rencontre notamment
Darty Darty heure des forces militaires
ukrainiennes encore une fois ont appelé
à plus de à plus de munitions livrées
par par l'Occident certains étaient
soulagés d'ailleurs de voir jobiden
faire le déplacement à qui et il voyait
même un signe Annonciation de nouvelles
livraisons d'armes mais pour l'instant
la situation est compliquée pour eux ils
disposait essentiellement c'est-à-dire à
75 % de matériel soviétique ils veulent
des armes plus puissantes plus précises
de fabrication occidentale il commence
aussi à s'inquiéter du manque de
munitions un manque de munition qui
concerne aussi ce vieux matériel russe
puisque l'essentiel de ces munitions
sont fabriquées par la rue sous par la
Russie ou par la Chine et là aussi il y
a une forme d'inquiétude donc une
position ici à l'Est plutôt une position
défensive puisque nous confier ces
artilleurs ils n'ont pas suffisamment de
munitions pour contracter mais pour
l'instant il continue de résister merci
beaucoup Karim et oui pour ces éléments
en direct de la région de Denis que donc
dans le don-basse pour France 24